when you shoot a movie like war dogs are
there scenes where you have trouble with
like you have to keep taking it over and
over again because you know you're not
nailing it I have been
known to do to do things over and over
again maybe because you think you're not
getting it right the only issue I've
ever had from another actor who's a good
friend of mine Named Sam Rockwell I
reset myself a lot in in the scene yeah
meaning like I'll say a line a few times
in a row yeah and I had to I had to
change that a little bit because Sam was
nice enough to tell me it's like kind of
disrespectful to the other actors in a
lot of ways to not play the whole entire
scene out right you understand I learned
acting through making movies right you
didn't go to acting school I did but I
dropped out so quickly that I don't have
the toolbox that a lot of other actors
have supposedly it's rude if you don't
stick to the line because they don't
know where to come in well I never stick
to the line yet anyways that's just not
gonna happen I don't think and it's
funny when I work with like I worked
with the Cohen Brothers and they it was
incredible and they're like my some of
my heroes but what was amazing is
they're literally Maybe the most
brilliant writers
these men like these people should win
like Pulitzer prizes for their writing
right and I remember I kept doing I only
had one little scene in the movie but I
was happy to be there and I kept saying
like and or like there was some tiny
thing change and Ethan Cohen walks up to
me after he had told me a couple times
like you know this is the line or
whatever and I just kept botching this
one line and he came up to me and he
just put his hand on my shoulder and he
goes because he's very quiet and he was
just like Jonah you're um
you're actually
um
you're killing me
I'm gonna die
um and pass away because you didn't
say it how I I wrote it I want you to
say it um and it's just like in moments
like that and even with Tarantino too
he's such a brilliant writer but not
that I'm wasted in those environments
but it's not what I it's not what I do
isn't it because like you could get any
any in those two movies it maybe could
have been
any decent actor in that role because
they're such they're so brilliant you're
you're in their painting whereas like in
Wolf of Wall Street or or Moneyball or
this film or dogs like
you know what what the coolest thing
about modern Scorsese ever is it lets
you do your thing he he just loves to
see what you're gonna do right he enjoys
it like he loves to see and be surprised
yeah it's great with somebody for him
but that's the impression I I it's great
if somebody's good at it if they're not
they better stick to the [ __ ] script
yeah but that's what I I think that's
why you would hire me maybe if you want
to be you want to see things evolve or
you know and don't you think the movie
the best advice I got from him from
watching Martin Scorsese was
kind of like get out of the movie's way
it's like gonna become this other thing
like I watched Wolf of Wall Street
changed so much from when we were
rehearsing until when it was done you
know right he's just so next level it's
not even funny